[Musique]
bienvenue dans le duel des éditos votre
débat politique du jeudi soir au
sommaire cette semaine l'éducation
embauches en déficit et des missions en
excédent c'est la formule d'un métier en
plein malaise à l'éducation nationale
les profs jette l'épongé comment rendre
son attractivité à la profession et ses
lettres de noblesse à l'école de la
république
quelles propositions des candidats à la
présidentielle faut-il retenir
l'éducation nationale le chantier
oublier c'est le débat de la semaine
alexis poulin et jacques de guillebon
vous éclaire ensuite sur l'actualité
politique de demain dans le monde
d'après mais d'abord dans l'acte eu des
éditos retour sur l'allocution
d'emmanuel macro mardi soir le président
a ramené ses réformes sur la table celle
de l'assurance chômage entrera en
vigueur dès décembre quand celle des
retraites fera son retour en 2022
d'ailleurs messieurs établir un
calendrier avant même sa candidature
n'est ce pas un peu présomptueux de la
part du président
on verra les six jours jacques donc oui
emmanuel macron est en plus qu'en pré
campagne est en campagne et nous annonce
le calendrier de ce qu'il va faire sur
le son quinquennat à venir ont déjà il a
déjà un programme et notamment sur les
sur les retraites la réforme qui l'a pas
fait et dont il nous dit qu'il faudrait
les réduire pour qu'il la fasse demain
bah alors la réforme des retraites
justement il en parlait c'était un gros
grosse partie de cette allocution on va
écouter ce qu'il dit à ce propos
d'ailleurs
dès 2022 il faudra pour préserver les
pensions de nos retraités et la
solidarité entre nos générations prendre
des décisions claires
elles feront légitimement l'objet de
débat démocratique indispensable
mais elles devront suivre à mes yeux des
principes simples
travailler plus longtemps en repoussant
l'âge légal aller vers un système plus
juste en supprimant les régimes spéciaux
en harmonisant les règles entre public
et privé et en faisant en sorte qu'au
terme d'une carrière complète aucune
pension ne puisse être inférieure à 1000
euros alors là on a le en même temps
puisque dans le programme du candidat
macron 2017 il ne reculait pas l'âge de
la retraite bon là il dit il y aura
débat démocratique mais il faudra
travailler plus longtemps de toute façon
le débat est déjà tranchée en réalité on
voit bien les partenaires sociaux ont
tout fait pour que cette réforme n'ait
pas lieu le coville a aidé à ce qu'elle
n'ait pas lieu mais il veut remettre ça
sur la table pour 2022 c'est la réforme
qu'il portait finalement avec c'est en
même temps un toujours j'ai promis un
truc puis j'en fais un autre voilà ça
c'est typiquement un maquereau nice tu
sais ça et encore il est gentil legrand
président macro on nous dit qu'on aura
droit à un débat démocratique oui même
s'il est réélu alors souhaitait déjà
transférer ses yeux être naturel il va
être élu forcément c'est ce qui va se
passer en 2022 il est très sympathique
comme de nous laisser encore débattre un
petit peu on a dit bon on a de la chance
alors après c'est cette allocution elle
était surréaliste puisque lui à des
chiffres que visiblement nous n'avons
pas il vit dans un pays où le gall plein
emploi quasiment où on peine à recruter
oubliant de dire qu'il ya treize fois
plus de chômeurs que deux postes vacants
les soignants sont heureux comme tout
l'état va très bien
on a un pays en pleine croissance alors
d'à côté les entreprises vont recevoir
le prêt garanti par l'état jusqu'en juin
2022 après l'élection mais les chômeurs
par contre la réforme est faite il
faudra avoir travaillé six mois dans les
deux ans plutôt que quatre mois dans les
deux ans précédant la mise au chômage
pour avoir droit à des allocations alors
même que ces allocations elles sont
payées bien sûr par les travailleurs
avant qu'ils soient au chômage cette
réforme là par contre elle peut avoir
lieu c'est la seule qui finalement il
aura pu mettre en place une réforme qui
va davantage précarisés certains
français qui va encore faire peur sur
l'avenir alors que lui pense que les
français bien ils sont contents que tout
va bien et que alors sanitaires ces avis
un quasiment maintenant c'est là qu'on
voit le quoi qu'il en coûte en fait on
voit qui ça va coûter ça va compter
notamment aux chômeurs va vous remettre
au travail ces fainéants et donc en plus
d'un côté on nous dit il ya plus de
chômage et bien en baisse comme jamais
mais en revanche il est encore trop de
chômeurs qu'il faut remettre au travail
parce qu'ils n'ont pas envie de le
travailler évidemment concepteurs c'est
aussi ça le souci et quand il se vante
de ses 6 % de croissance faut pas
oublier que 2020 c'est moins 8% de
croissance personne n'y peut rien c'est
le virus ont finement et 6% de
croissance c'est juste un rattrapage de
ce qu'ils avaient avant donc sais c'est
pas non plus la folie mais en plus on
n'a pas tout vu encore puisqu'à partir
de janvier la france à prendre la tête
de la présidence de l'union européenne
oui emmanuel macron va en profiter pour
encore une fois vous parler de son
programme à venir pour les 10 ans ou 20
ans à venir peut-être si jamais des
réformes l'élection présidentielle est
qu'on peut avoir des quinquennats jamais
et maquereau a jamais puisque la priori
il est capable de tout il est capable de
tout régler c'est ça qui est merveilleux
il est donc cette allocution on sait
toujours pas pourquoi elle a eu lieu
exactement peut-être pour nous rassurer
on va pas totalement rationnelle pour
vous pour vous demander des loups alors
enfin avec ce même si je pense que c'est
lui qui veut se rassurer il ya quelque
chose d'assez fébrile dans cette fin de
quinquennat où ils voient bien que il un
bilan indéfendable calamiteux donc il
est en train de me maquiller c'est un
peu comme vendre une voiture volée et il
va nous dire c'est un bilan formidable
derrière on voit bien lui même je pense
n'y croit pas il a menti sur toute la
ligne le pass sanitaire c'est jusqu'en
juillet 2022 date de la fin de la
présidence de l'union européenne
d'ailleurs de la france la troisième
dose en août au lit et veyran disait
elle ne sera pas rentré dans le pass
sanitaires et bien pas ta trace oui pour
les plus de 65 ans c'est maintenant une
troisième dose obligatoire pour
conserver son pass sanitaires on le voit
bien il ya quelque chose là de l'ordre
du fébrile dans durant ce quinquennat
emmanuel macron aura fait deux
conférences de presse il n'aura répondu
à la presse que deux fois de manière
libre le reste du temps c'était des
interviews exclusives ou bien la
dernière fois qu'il a eu des gens qui
l'ont confronté c'était mcfly et carlito
à l'elysée c'est dire un peu ce
président comme il a peur finalement
d'être confronté à des questions qui
fâchent c'est vrai mais si on revient à
notre sujet alexis c'est à dire la
question des retraites on peut dire
qu'il n'est pas dans le même temps ou
alors qu'il est comme tout libéral
conséquent en même temps c'est à dire de
gauche et droite qui va prendre des voix
la bourgeoisie de gauche mais pour faire
des réformes de droite les skis propose
pour sa réforme des retraites c'est ce
que propose la droite libérale depuis
six heures et trente ans c'est la même
chose toujours c'est repousser l'âge de
la retraite voilà fondre les régimes
spéciaux comme citoyen j'ai spéciaux été
la même chose y en a aucun qui n'avait
plus aucune valeur et qu'il avait pas
des personnes qui avaient le droit à un
statut différent selon la pénibilité de
leur travail et c'est évidemment encore
une fois voilà travailler plus plus
longtemps donc pénaliser le travailleur
aujourd'hui donc c'est vraiment on est
dans la wii on est dans la logique la
plus libérale possible qui va plaire à
la droite anciennement heller et oui le
fond de son électorat aujourd'hui on
voit bien la dynamique qu'il essaie de
mettre en place ces deux d'en finir avec
cave après avoir exposé la gauche a
explosé la droite classique à la droite
des républicains en leur volant tous les
thèmes de campagne en leur volant
également toutes les idées sur le
travailler plus c'est pas nouveau sur la
valeur travail ce mot a été rabâchée
pendant cette allocution le travail
alors le travail pourquoi emmanuel
macron n'aime pas le terme pénibilité
parce que ça voudrait dire que le
travail est pénible mais il ya des
accidents du travail à des morts au
travail de travail des emplois qui sont
difficiles à faire sur le temps long
hélas il ne veut pas le voir tout comme
les chômeurs pour lui
il est dans cette fable que le chômeur
c'est quelqu'un d'inactifs qui ne
cherche pas un travail et je trouve du
boulot et qui gagnent plus en étant au
chômage qu'en travaillant ce qui est
totalement faux donc on a eu encore une
allocution
délirante presque pour défendre un bilan
qui est indéfendable aujourd'hui
place aux débats de la semaine - deux
candidats au concours et des démissions
multiplié par trois en dix ans mais où
sont nos profs si à marseille emmanuel
macron s'est engagé à remettre à neuf
les écoles primaires l'épineuse question
de la rémunération elle fait l'école
buissonnière
salaires qui stagnent à 1700 euros
sentiment de déclassement une école
torpillée par les réformes les symptômes
du malaise enseignant se multiplient
pour 2022 chaque candidat y va de sa
solution doubler les salaires pour anne
hidalgo créer des postes pour jean luc
mélenchon ouvrir l'apprentissage aux
plus jeunes pour michel barnier alors
comment faire de l'école le bon élève de
la fonction publique ouvrons le débat
avec une première question comment
expliquer que le plus beau métier du
monde soit devenu le pire métier du
monde
ah oui c'est vrai que c'est à améthier
d'ailleurs que les professeurs
continuent de faire avec passion même
s'il le trouve de plus en plus difficile
par manque de moyens bien sûr par
l'explosion aussi du nombre d'élèves
dans les classes on a fermé beaucoup
trop de classe et aussi le fait que les
programmes changent tout le temps la
façon d'apprendre à lire écrire les
fondamentaux finalement on a
l'impression que chaque année on re
découvre on a un ministère de
l'éducation nationale qui va dire au
professeur qu'il faut changer de méthode
que ça ne va pas et qu'il faut faire
quelque chose d'autre et puis les
confinements n'ont pas aidé on a là les
plus jeunes qui ont des déficits énormes
pour l'apprentissage et l'acquisition de
la lecture et de l'écriture parce que ce
confinement était extrêmement difficile
et que l'école à la maison c'est
difficile à faire les parents n'ont pas
l'habitude et on voit bien que ce métier
là malgré toutes les bonnes volontés du
monde c'est un peu comme les soignants
c'est casser encore une fois par le néo
management public par l'idée de faire
une école différente cas c'est la faux
cils la valeur travail là pour le bruit
valeur d'apprentissage pour avoir une
école finalement du flux où on va
emmener une classe d'âge vers le chômage
bravo non mais c'est surtout que ça oui
c'est un métier qui n'est pas du tout
valorisé je pensais aujourd'hui c'était
avant les hussards noirs faisait la
république était le la structure même de
la république étaient ceux qui devaient
accompagner le peuple vers les lumières
aujourd'hui ils sont maltraités le prof
est méprisé d'ailleurs on va en écoute
et témoignages de professeurs à ce sujet
là ça fait une quinzaine d'années que on
n'est pas le pontiac d'ici les jeunes et
donc les salaires n'augmentent pas le
seul moyen d'avoir un salaire meyers et
de
déchoir un échelon et on est les profs
nous les plus mal payés d'europe et de
plus nous on a fait un calcul la mois
sur 15 ans
pour qu'elles ont à peu près mais c'est
un manque à gagner de 385 euros sur les
salaires dans l'établissement on va
accueillir plus d'élèves à la rentrée
prochaine et nous aurons moins de moyens
pour les prendre en charge concrètement
il y aura des suppressions de postes
concrètement il ya des heures qui vont
diminuer
donc nous n'avons pas les moyens
d'accueillir des élèves en difficulté de
manière satisfaisante
comment ne pourrait-on pas avoir peur
quand on voit que les concours de
recrutement n'attire plus et s'il
n'attire plus c'est parce que les
carrières sont dévalorisées parce que
les métiers sont dévalorisés et parce
que du coup on n'a pas investi sur le
long terme dans l'éducation dans cette
dame qu'on entende n est pas tout à fait
raison mais presque quand il dit on et
des professeurs les moins bien payés
d'europe life il ya guère que l'italie
et le portugal qui traite plus mal leurs
enseignants que la france mais ce qui
est scandaleux c'est quand vous regardez
le salaire des professeurs en allemagne
aux côtés de celui des français c'est à
dire que le professeur allemand et payer
quasiment deux fois mieux que le
professeur français et que je sache on
n'est pas une économique et moitié celle
de l'allemagne encore parce que en
france on a fait le choix de payer les
murs disons si on a beaucoup de
d'établissement de lycées et de collèges
de primaire ce qui va une mauvaise chose
puisqu'il ya une certaine proximité mais
en revanche beaucoup d'investissements
vont là dedans et le salaire des
professeurs restent misérable surtout
quand vous avez fait dans des métropoles
en région parisienne il ya vous pouvez
pas vivre avec ça décemment alors que
c'est un métier qui doit évidemment être
valorisé puisque c'est à la base de la
république oui alors ce gel du point
d'indicé il a fait extrêmement mal mais
ça date bien avant ça en réalité les
professeurs français sont impayés
ailleurs qu'en europe sauf comme vous
l'avez dit en italie au portugal mais la
vérité c'est que au delà de la
proposition fantaisiste d'anne hidalgo
de doubler le salaire des profs
immédiatement blanc caire c'est bien
qu'il ya un problème le ministre de
l'éducation nationale lui propose
d'augmenter progressivement sur cinq ans
ce salaire
mais on voit bien un salaire minimum ses
1700 8 euros nets la proposition du
gouvernement c'est de revaloriser à 1869
euros en début de carrière le problème
c'est que les écoles ferment depuis 2009
4700 écoles ont fermé et il ya de plus
en plus d'élèves et je ne vois pas
comment l'équation peut faire que
l'éducation va être de qualité si on
ferme des postes si on a du mal à
recruter parce qu'évidemment c'est un
métier qui peine à recruter là encore
est que les élèves sont de plus en plus
nombreux on a l'impression d'ailleurs
que hôpital école c'est un peu le même
schéma qui se met en place c'est à dire
faire plus avec moins une économie du
flux une économie aussi qui doit être
ouvert au privé et pas forcément aux
services publics avec dédé des agents
publics maltraités je suis d'accord avec
vous et ça se manifeste notamment dans
les démissions des enseignants ce qui
n'est pas seulement le fait qu'il ait
moins deux chiffres aujourd'hui c'est
que même si c'est pas c'est pas de
gigantesques non plus en chiffres bruts
mans tout casser ça a été multipliée je
crois par trois ou quatre depuis dix ans
et une démission c'est à dire qu'avant
ça l'arrivée très peu puisque un
désavantage des enseignants c'est
d'avoir un post avis la sécurité de
l'emploi et c'est aussi ça qui
recherchait et certain confort dans
l'aménagement des horaires n'est qu'ils
se sentent comme beaucoup de français
comme beaucoup de professions de plus en
plus maltraité ses parts par ce monde où
ils sont mal payés par l'état pas
reconnu et où parlons-en aussi un petit
peu il ya aussi l'agressivité qui vient
du côté des élèves et des parents juste
qui se répand et des parents aussi qui
se répand de plus en plus on l'a vu sans
parler du cad à freud et le samuel baty
on voit comment les professeurs sont de
moins en moins protégé par l'état par
laquelle leurs employeurs qui sont de
moins en moins suivi et d et que leurs
fonctions quel sens est celle de
l'autorité de celle qu'on respecte les
de moins en moins mais comme comme on le
voit pour les policiers par ailleurs
pour les juges aussi bref il ya aussi
qu'ils se jouent dans la société c'est
pas uniquement
l'état qu'il est père est moins bien
c'est aussi à ce voile à ce respect a
disparu ballet l'état les pme mais aussi
le statut social a complètement changé
un professeur agrégé gagné cinq fois
plus que le salaire médian c'est
maintenant 2 5 fois plus enfin on voit
bien qu'il ya un déclassement de toutes
façons de ce métier qui était un métier
plutôt honorable à métier quasiment
bourgeois comme vous étiez professeur
agrégé c'est plus le cas du tout on a
affaire aussi à des professeurs qui eux
sont face à élèves et qu'ils ont affaire
à des inspecteurs généraux un rectorat à
des pédagogues qui leur apprennent
finalement qu'un enfant c'est pas du
tout ce qu'ils ont en face d'eux et puis
alors il ya une école fantasmée de la
république je sais pas si vous avez vu
la série du service public où là on a
carrément inventé une école où tout
irait bien où finalement le l'idéologie
hockey est au coeur d'un dispositif et
c'est pas du tout ça les professeurs
vous disent qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup
de conflits dans les classes alors
parfois ça se passe bien et heureusement
mais ça reste un métier quand même où la
pédagogie joue un rôle énorme et où
l'autorité évidemment s'est délité comme
vous le disiez et les difficiles à
remettre parce que derrière il n'y a pas
du tout politique alors si on a quand
même jean michel blanquer air qui a
sorti le carré régaliens alors c'est
magnifique je sais pas si vous avez vu
ce petit dispositif alors c'est un petit
carré avec un drapeau français qu'il a
fait à graffer dans tous les collèges et
lycées de france qui expliquent le
respect donc il faut pour que ça marche
l'école de la république le respect des
valeurs de la république la prévention
des violences la lutte contre le
harcèlement et la prévention de la
radicalisation voilà ce que doivent
faire les professeurs alors ça va
drôlement aider cette petite flèche qui
tire de tous les côtés on a l'impression
qu'ils sont écartelés pour pour ne rien
dire autrement et c'est le drapeau
français qu'on écarte elle finalement à
savoir qu'est ce que vous voulez faire
de ça voilà les outils pédagogiques
qu'on donne aux professeurs aujourd'hui
sous le ministère de jean michel
blanquer c'est assez inquiétant
merveilleux et wii dont il est le fait
que marseille qui est deuxième ville de
france ait besoin d'un tel arrêt
investissements matériels et comme
frappant çà veut dire qu'on a laissé se
déliter des écoles des lycées et des
collèges depuis le depuis 20 ans dont
les on nous dit qu'un tiers de ces
écoles sont dans une situation
préoccupante parce qu'ils auraient des
problèmes d'étanchéité d'infiltration
des sanitaires des failles enfin bref à
l'image de ce service public oui qui n'a
pas plu réinvestis et où aujourd'hui on
découvre qu'il faut le faire mais après
au delà ça je pense que le cas de
marseille est aussi due en partie à
justement ce qu'on disait sur cette
cette absence d'autorité des professeurs
c'est ce manifestations d'agressivité
des élèves je pense qu'il ya l'école
publique était censé être le sanctuaire
de la république est un endroit qui
n'est plus du tout contrôler ou de moins
en moins dans certains endroits et où
tout est détruit toute la journée et où
les professeurs n'ont plus aucune
autorité faire respecter mais c'est
aussi le jeu je pense de la
décentralisation parce que vous avez d'à
côté à ministère une éducation nationale
et puis les écoles qui sont aussi
dépendante des départements des villes
des régions voilà ça dépend totalement
et donc on se renvoie la balle quand il
faut réparer qu'1 sanitaire qui un toit
ça peut prendre beaucoup trop de temps
par rapport à ce qui pourrait être fait
si c'était coordonnées donc l'abandon il
est là il est aussi dans les discours
enel macron par une fois d'école quand
il va à marseille pour dire qu'il va
faire des cadeaux simplement des chèques
pour rénover le bâti dans son allocution
présidentielle quasiment rien sur
l'éducation quasiment rien sur les
enfants sur la formation des citoyens de
demain qu'est ce qu'on va en faire et on
entend des discours qui sont là pour
dire que l'école doit être ouverte à
l'entreprise qui va falloir créer
finalement des filières l'apprentissage
évidemment qui a été un des indes est un
des plus une des priorités de ce
quinquennat défendue aussi par par
michel barnier et d'autre mais c'est pas
c'est pas seulement ça derrière l'école
il ya l'apprentissage aussi de ce que
c'est qu'être français qu'être citoyen
français et ça on demande aux
professeurs de le faire avec ce fameux
carré régaliens c'est peut avec le peu
de temps aussi qui est dédié à
l'éducation civique
et à l'apprentissage de ce fameux alors
le terme peut être difficile entendez le
vivre ensemble il est là il est à
l'école avec ces valeurs là oui oui je
suis d'accord avec vous mais demandez
encore une fois à l'école de faire
uniquement des citoyens français sans
s'appesantir sur les sur les compétences
qu'on leur apprend c'est encore tapé à
côté quand vous riez le classement de la
france dans les tous les fins dans tous
les classements internationaux
c'est pathétique c'est à dire qu'on
n'arrive plus à enseigner à nos enfants
aujourd'hui le le niveau en
mathématiques d'un élève de 4e et celui
de d'un élève de 5e me dis à 10 ans fait
dans le même pays si la grève est une
chute sur tous les niveaux comme ça et
ça je vois pas dans les dents les
candidats actuels lesquels ont des
vraies propositions là dessus vous dites
l'apprentissage qui voilà que le serpent
de mer qu'on ressort à chaque fois parce
que regarder nos amis allemands font
d'apprentissage et c'est très bien ça
permet de s'insérer sur le marché du
travail et séraphin s'est très bien
d'accord mais ça ne nous dit pas comment
on va essayer de remonter le niveau qui
est globalement catastrophique comme on
peut le constater lors il ya valérie
pécresse qui parle d'un bilan de
compétences en sixième pour savoir si
les acquis sont agri juste avant de
sortir oui mais là on parle de la 6e
étape pour passer dans l'école
élémentaire n'apprend plus à lire et à
écrire donc il faut savoir si on 6e on a
affaire des élèves qui savent lire et
écrire on en est là et puis vous avez
les pouvoirs publics qui ont accompagné
cette dégringolade avec la réforme du
bac et la réforme du bac c'est quoi
c'est un bac à la carte finalement pour
dire bon bah puisque le bac 90 % d'une
classe d'âge avec le bac ça ne veut plus
rien dire arrêtons le diplôme faisons
semblant essayons d'accompagner là aussi
avec un diplôme du contrôle continu pour
arriver finalement sur un marché de
l'emploi ou de l'éducation supérieure là
encore éducation supérieure beaucoup de
chantiers en cours qui qui qui manque de
moyens et puis au delà de la formation
des professeurs on a vu qu'elle a été
changé ces dernières années il ya aussi
le monde de l'éducation supérieure de la
recherche nous chercheurs qui quitte la
france qui ne sont pas payés eux non
plus c'est à dire que tout un monde de
l'université à l'école élémentaire qui
tacle vicieux voilà un monde qui est en
train de se déliter et on n'arrive plus
à former même en ayant augmenté en
passant de la licence au m2 pour devenir
professeur
on voit que le niveau n'augmentent pas
non je dis vous avez des académies
notamment à créteil par exemple ou à
versailles et qui manque de professeurs
ils sont obligés de faire d'emblée
second concours de recrutement où ils
abaissent le niveau d'admission c'est à
dire que prendre si vous les professeurs
en bretagne le niveau d'émissions et a13
disons si vous voulez rentrer à créteil
dans la seconde vague c à 5 vous avez 5
vous êtes vous devez des professeurs
bravo mais c'est même plus des
professeurs d'heure on a affaire
maintenant à des personnes externes des
contractuels le chiffre a explosé parce
que justement les professeurs eux
démissionne arrête de faire ce métier il
n'arrive plus à le faire et donc on est
en train de ba de faire une école à
privatiser une école à plusieurs
vitesses puisque l'école privée elle
essaye de récupérer le marché d'une
certaine façon elle est sous contrat
donc elle peut le faire mais il ya aussi
un mouvement parallèle qui voudraient
empêcher l'école autrement l'école à la
maison on a vu avec jean michel blanquer
requise est justement pour ces valeurs
régaliennes il faut absolument que les
enfants soient à l'école même si celle
ci ne fonctionne pas oui ce qui a choqué
beaucoup de parents d'ailleurs qu'ils
aiment et pourquoi quelle est la raison
finalement de pousser à cette
organisation sas et l'idiotie de la
république de voir une école
monolithique c'est à dire que on
persécute les écoles privées les écoles
hors contrat alors que ça pourrait faire
une saine émulation et montrer quels
sont les systèmes d'enseignement qui
marche mais ça on a l'impression que
personne ne se meut veut chercher ça
qu'on a peur en fait qu'il y ait cette
émulation et qu'on reste dans une
médiocrité on stagne et où tout le monde
est content dans cette médiocrité
direction le monde d'après alexis poule
a et jacques de guillebon vous apportent
leur éclairage chaque semaine sur une
information qui pourrait faire
l'actualité politique de demain
commençons par vous jacques selon vous
quelles infos mérite cette semaine un
coup de projecteur
moi je viens vous parler de tout ce
gaulliste aujourd'hui c'est à dire on a
vu cette semaine le défilé de tout le
monde à colombey-les-deux-églises à
bayeux partout parce que c'était
l'anniversaire de mort du général de
gaulle mais surtout quelqu'un qui me
fascine qui est michel barnier ce
candidat à la candidature des
républicains qui vous dis aujourd'hui
les yeux dans les yeux je suis le
contraire d'un technocrate et je ne suis
pas non plus un fédéraliste européen je
suis gaulliste je crois à la coopération
des nations avec nos voisins très beau
et que disait le même michel barnier en
2012 il est que la crise de montrer
qu'on ne peut pas s'en sortir tout seul
le temps nous est compté d'ici à 2016
l'union l'union européenne dos reis être
transformée en une génération des états
européens dans lesquels les nations
mutualiseront leurs destins sans effacer
leur différend soit 2007 d'une
libération c'est ça donc les face à ces
ce qu'ils voyaient en 2012 ou en 2007 en
disant allons vers cet avenir un
merveilleux où leur une fédération
d'états européens un grand chef européen
qui est comme chacun sait tout à fait du
gaullisme qui est même l'un verse
maintenant rennais aujourd'hui emboîtant
le pas de tout le monde ils sont tous
devenus gaullistes même les républicains
qui vous disent qu'ils en sont les
héritiers parce qu'il ya une une fac
tradition qui va jusqu'à eux et qu' ils
font assaut de politique de la chaise
vide de weeds critique de de l'union
européenne de la fédération européenne
en dix ans seuls les états sont
souverains les nations c'est uniquement
là qu'on peut régler le problème alors
qu'ils vous disais exactement l inverse
il ya pas moins de 10 ans mais c'est
beau comme du maquereau c'était
exactement la même chose alors il va
changer de route de discours d qui va
prendre la présidence de l'union
européenne mais on est exactement dans
ce en même temps ou de ce reniement
perpétuelle parce qu'il ya plutôt eu non
vertébrales politique finalement au sein
de ce personnel politique là moi je
voulais parler d'un autre animal
politique c'est arnaud montebourg à
bangalore arnaud montebourg il a lancé
sa campagne avec la remonte à dar l'idée
c'était de le redire rires d'utiliser la
france remonte bouhriz et la france et
puis patatras voilà qu'il a parlé du
transfert d'argent des travailleurs
immigrés vers les pays africains avec
western union entre autres en disant
qu'il fallait empêcher ces transferts
attaquer les pays et les empêcher
résultat c'est la débandade à la
dégringolade a quasiment là fini ta dah
de la campagne les jeunes avec
montebourg qui était
en avait quelques-uns ont fermé le
compte twitter lancé à communiqué de
presse en disant on arrête alors de
nouveaux jeunes avec montebourg sont
arrivés certains supports de la gauche
républicaine et socialistes l'ont dit on
arrête la campagne avec arnaud
montebourg il s'est rendu compte
évidemment de la bourde énorme qui
l'avait fait pour lui en tant que
candidat de gauche vient de sortir un
truc pareil le mal est fait j'ai
l'impression qu'il aura du mal à
rattraper les wagons la campagne de
montebourg me semble difficilement
sauvade ah oui oui lui n'a pas attendu
dix ans contrairement à bernier pour se
dédire lui c'était le lendemain que
c'était dit non mais ce que j'ai dit
était très clair mais si vous n'avez pas
compris c'est que c'était pas clair et
pourrait expliquer que j'ai fait je
jeunesse une parce que j'ai ce que j'ai
dit hier
voilà mais c'est assez pathétique sur
l'amateurisme qui règne par cette
campagne et notamment à gauche je trouve
aujourd'hui une impréparation totale qui
d'ailleurs en dit long sur l'idée qu'ils
se font d'une campagne politique et d'un
poste comme celui de président de la
république on va en parler en mairie
campagne la semaine prochaine on se
revoit la semaine prochaine sur ce même
plateau
au revoir c'est la fin du duel des
éditos vous pouvez retrouver cette
émission en replay sur notre site rt
france point tv et en podcast sur toutes
les plateformes vous pouvez également
réagir dans les commentaires et sur les
réseaux sociaux via le hashtag ldd eux à
la semaine prochaine pour un nouveau
duel d tous
[Musique]